SETH VARGO: In this episode
of the Google Secret Manager
video series, we'll
talk about how
Secret Manager can aid
in threat detection
and forensic analysis.
Where can you find a
list of all requests
to Google Secret Manager?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
While we always want
to do as much as we
can to prevent a data breach,
a good security threat model
also accounts for the
unexpected and helps us respond
in the event of a compromise.
All too often, organizations
invest all their resources
in prevention and then
they leave no bandwidth
for detection or recovery.
Cloud Audit Logging is a
fully managed logging service
that, once enabled,
provides a forensic history
of interactions with
Google Secret Manager.
It also works with other
Google Cloud products,
but this episode focuses
specifically on Secret Manager.
To tell us more about
Cloud Audit Logging
and how it can help
with forensics,
I think we need to
bring in an expert.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Tommy.
Thanks for joining us today.
TOMMY MURPHY: Thanks, Seth.
Thank you for having me.
SETH VARGO: So Tommy is
a software engineer who
works on Google Secret Manager.
Tommy, earlier, I was telling
our viewers about Cloud Audit
Logging and how it
keeps a detailed list
of all interactions with
Google Secret Manager.
TOMMY MURPHY:
That's right, Seth.
But there's an
important first step.
SETH VARGO: Oh, what's that?
TOMMY MURPHY: You
have to turn them on.
Admin write audit logs, which
include any changes to secrets,
are enabled by
default. But admin
read logs, which include
viewing secret metadata,
and data read logs,
which log secret access,
are disabled by default
because of the amount of data
they generate.
SETH VARGO: OK.
But what if I have
my secret stored
across multiple projects?
Do I have to enable it on each
project, or how does that work?
TOMMY MURPHY: You can
enable cloud audit logs
on a per-product basis.
And you can choose
to enable logs
for admin read, admin write,
data read, data write,
or any combination.
SETH VARGO: OK.
But to rephrase
my last question,
where do I turn them on,
at the project level,
or how do I manage
this at scale?
TOMMY MURPHY: Great question.
Cloud audit logs are
configured through IAM
and can be enabled
on a single project,
for all projects in a
folder, or for all projects
in an entire organization.
This means a security
team can configure
an organization-wide
policy that automatically
applies to all current
and future projects.
SETH VARGO: OK.
And then what do I do
after I turn them on?
TOMMY MURPHY: That's it.
SETH VARGO: Oh, this is
kind of awkward then.
TOMMY MURPHY: Why?
SETH VARGO: We just--
we had a lot more back-and-forth
with our other experts.
I guess Cloud Audit Logging
really is this easy.
TOMMY MURPHY: Yep.
I'm going to go now.
SETH VARGO: Cool.
Thanks, Tommy.
TOMMY MURPHY: Thanks, Seth.
SETH VARGO: OK.
Let's look at how we enable
and consume cloud audit
logs for Google Secret Manager.
Now that we've enabled
Cloud Audit Logging,
all requests to access and
manage secrets in this project
will generate a log entry.
I'll go ahead and
access a secret
so it generates such
an audit log entry.
These audit logs are written to
Cloud Logging, Google Cloud's
centralized logging solution,
which you can easily
access from the sidebar.
From here, you can
filter by log type,
including audit logs
for particular services.
For example, suppose
you suspected
that a service
account credential had
been compromised.
Here in the Log Viewer, you
can filter for all requests
to access secrets using
that service account.
You can then correlate that data
against timestamps, source IP
addresses, and more.
Google Secret
Manager's integration
with Cloud Audit
Logging brings a wealth
of forensic information
to your fingertips
with the click of a button.
That's all for this
episode, and this concludes
our Secret Manager series.
To learn more about
Secret Manager,
visit us on the web at
cloud.google.com/secret-manager.
And be sure to Like,
Subscribe, and click the bell
to get notifications about
new and upcoming video series
on security, AI, ML, databases,
storage, and so much more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]